oh my God
oh my gosh that thing is giant
they're horse flies
yeah
dead bodies [__] in the goddamn walls
what's going on you see it yes right
there that thing's [__] giant oh my
god get it holy [__] yeah this thing's
big as [__]
it off the camera
dude it's not even scared just grab it
Gareth go like this in the face smash it
they bite you take those little plastic
thing
learned your lesson with slavery this
here he is still there
we should tie a string to him then a
little loud
on the on the sucker yeah dude now we
got a pet fly
all right well
I hope your viewers enjoyed that no
what are you doing we've been live for a
minute so I don't know if it came across
or not I kind of want to re-watch it
anyway let me see it look it's moving oh
yeah that does nothing I'm just tired
hold on dude let it suffer no no let it
suffer I know you're supposed to be the
the heart and soul of the group you're
supposed to be the feminist no
no we can't have four Psychopaths
women have been forced to be around this
month is insane why are you forced to be
around women
oh
you're forced to be around women
push play okay
I can't believe you just caught it
happened right away it wouldn't move
dude it has no survival oh my gosh yeah
I did that very elegantly I think it's
dead remember that one yeah that's what
I'll say no
it's like
flipping [__] over
here afro looked on point the whole time
that that's the only thing I was worried
about
where am I going to place myself yeah
where are you getting those flies from
Hans I don't know where where are they
this is a cool neighborhood I think
there's a lot of natural life in this
neighborhood no there's nothing to do
buried in this wall dude this is such a
funny video
that should be posted yeah that's gotta
be a clue yeah that's the clip for sure
someone that's not lazy clipped that
[__] yeah and don't just make racial
jokes the Flies are attracted to black
people jokes I could I'd post that
I'm sorry my house is filthy and there's
flies everywhere but you should feel
right at home jamisha
all right we're not gonna say the button
Baker
Hans did you do acid or something last
night why are you so enthralled with
this [__] why dude just throw it on
the ground am I not supposed to be
enthralled by controlling life
I'm sorry I'll go back to vaping dude
there's a hole in it
we're gonna milk the comments oh my God
so weird we're gonna leave him alone
dude
we're gonna name him uh right now his
name is Henry oh my God it was the first
one to just okay
I was about to name it that [__]
I just don't want to feel the guts oh
yeah wishing between my fingers no
that's a big ass do you guys like hate
anyone you want to put that in
somebody's bed or like there no we don't
hate anyone Ridge not all of us are
conservatives oh my gosh not all of us
milk cows sir yeah really what's that
about yeah always touching titties
what's his name guys is it Henry or
what's his [__] name dude what's his
name guys
what a fun exercise
the Italian name what was his name Fredo
Fredo
phrase
what a piece of [__] dude right away
afraid of nothing rest in peace to the
[__] Fredo thinks Gareth looks like a
little [__]
he's a little [__] man I'll [__]
murder Fredo right now this has nothing
to do with uh Fredo ATX in Austin Texas
this is
that's exactly who we're talking about
yeah
do you see what it is herbal snuff what
the hell is that tobacco-free nicotine
free what it tastes like [__] it's
horrible is it not dip no it's nuts no
it's it's dip it's dip but it's horrible
it's not it has no tobacco no you want
to try it absolutely not
wait no sure I'll do it smell it sure
I'll do it whatever what the [__] fridge
can you hear
um
no okay I hear constant went where I
wanted to go it was very obvious right
yeah like when it why didn't Kara make
the right decision
it's [__] you we all know Gareth and
his decision-making abilities oh they're
not great sometimes they're
there you make a lot of bats what's a
bad decisions
tell us about the decision you made to
cut your own seat belt off oh yeah so I
was Hammer drunk driving my car no I'm
just kidding typical Texas story I know
I was in a Whataburger line and my
friend Patrick the party just goes oh
yeah [__] how do these work he pulled
out the seat belt cutter and I was like
oh you just do this and it worked really
well and it cut my seatbelt off and I
feel like an idiot I also put a hole in
my shirt so was there like a safety on
it huh well it was it dude it it
literally worked in like two seconds I
was like actually this makes me feel
really good if I ever had to use one of
these yeah because it works super yeah
because like if you can work out an
idiot if you can work out with
technology how to get all that force of
your arm using that motion into sharp
little point oh yeah and just make it
cut really easily dude that was the
thing is I didn't even I just did that
like it was just like it just happened
like immediately and uh yeah now that
cost me two hundred dollars
no that's not well they should have like
a safety on it like a guard to be like
hey it's not on if you want to turn it
on
but honestly most people don't [__]
around with seat belt Cutters that much
for it to be a problem no I'm just a
giant idiot it's the thing and uh do you
know why you had it yeah I have it there
in case of an emergency that's what it's
there for like I keep it in my uh window
thing right there where the the window
blocker do you all not have one of those
no no really no wow you got it yeah you
know why because there's a button on the
seat belt that releases it
that's the whole point of the cutter is
if the button is jammed so you can't ah
the comments undo it jammed buttons but
you can also loosen the seat belt and
you can slide out of it
if you're underwater if you're under I
don't know man here well yeah I mean I
think it's a nice thing to have it's
good to if you have a bunch of these
things it's be good to be able to cut it
I see seat belts everywhere I might
might have to cut one yeah you should
have the tools to [__] up anything that
you see every day like you should have
like a [__]
stairs Destroyer oh my God that would be
great what is this thing for oh this is
a giant hole in the stairs so wait so
did that happen
listening from now
this is right now horrible it's been a
long South by what's up
my finger in my door car door yeah
fandor I mean slammed your finger in
another dude's ass
that's hilarious give me this smokeless
that means I have sex with dudes which
is funny that's right
what give me what happens if you light
it on fire the smokeless tobacco yeah
um I'm not sure I've never done that
what if you put it in a in a you wrote
up like a blunt and smoke it I don't
know but it's smooth yeah like are you
not supposed to smoke it like in a blunt
or I guess so I don't know good point it
probably doesn't light on fire
and then I decided against it
well I'm also an alcoholic so that's
that's a thing is that a bad decision
wait did you do that last night the cut
your you cut your seatbelt last night
last week oh last week no I uh I did not
cut my seat belt we thought that was yes
this is a week ago
yeah so you decided to wear that shirt
yeah
it's Texas I was like no there's no
yeah it makes you look really trashy
it's a texture shirt yeah it makes you
look really trashy it makes you look
because the shirt's kind of faded yeah
so it looks like it's been sweated on oh
for sure you're sort of out of shape
I love this I don't know how they're
friends
I want some good I love your shirt
jamita oh thank you but I appreciate it
so pretty thank you the flowers
here I'm kidding I hope sorry do you
think style is important no
then why do you have so much of it
I feel like you're criticizing me and
complimenting me at the same time and I
don't know how to answer that well then
that's a neutral thing I don't I mean
like I feel like I dress just like
appropriately and I just buy things that
I like I really like sweats
so I wear a lot of sweats but then I
like like just like jeans nice blouses
the fly got out of the bag no way
I told you [__]
and you did not listen how did it get
out of the best holes in the bag that
are not small holes
we all recognize you're right oh God God
damn
Gareth is still your turn I know man I'm
gonna figure this out hold on oh
I want to witness its death is it on
your camera again oh there he is
he's always
kill him
he got it's just like a harambe dude
oh [__] no I don't think that is gonna
kill this guy turn on the fan
no no no
it's gonna make a noise it's I don't
think the salt gun's gonna work on it
man
it's just bouncing off of this [__]
it's a big [__] dude oh my God kill him
let's see it
did you go dude
that's a big oh Ridge
okay red so you're down
there okay
did it not dry yet oh yeah it's dead
all right guys I'm aware that I I had a
mental breakdown and I just want to
apologize on behalf of um what did you
win I don't think you did
you have a mental break you had a mental
breakdown kidding this game is going to
be the longest game I've ever played
going at this rate we'll be chasing a
fly around I hope it's now we're gonna
finish this game in less than uh two
hours I think
I thought you were gonna say a time
frame that was right uh shorter than
that so yeah shorter than two hours
right I could have had a great life but
he got cocky and tried to escape yeah
exactly he was go right in his house we
gave him generous air holes
okay let the games they were big air
holes let the games begin
my turn
I need
I don't need dice yes you do yeah okay
you roll no you don't gridge oh sorry I
don't need those no she needs to place
her last settlement and then she is good
to go and she can roll
ing rolling rolling rolling the hell are
you laughing now she just has to place
her last settlement and I started the
sentence and so I'll just say random
words
shut the [__] up pawns this is how I
live my life okay
this is how we do things in the Austin
and the Austin Austin Texas did you just
have a feeling and then you open your
mouth and hope it makes sense
well yeah
that's isn't that what everybody's doing
it's a seat belt cutter it cuts seat
belts
[Laughter]
this is true it does do that and you
know are you figuring camera too all
right pick up your last settlement
cameras
I fixed it hopefully
sorry Anna you said pick up your last
settlement a woman I gotta report that
that's not right
oh Ridge
is just so
ancient in his Traditions who's more
ancient me or Gareth with Gareth not
allowing smoking on
what no dude I you know you can do
whatever you want that's fine that's
totally okay
um I just don't condone your actions
guys you think there should be a level
of decorum and politeness a thin veneer
a fakery to life no yeah absolutely I
think everybody said that charm I think
so if not I think everybody needs to
have a little bit of you know just we
gotta respect each other's personal
space you know you don't want to invade
people's personal space by smoking weed
on a podcast no that's fine I'm not
gonna be the one that says no
oh all right here goes our first turn
looks trashier to cut your seatbelt off
with the seatbelt cutter for no reason
oh yeah for sure yeah that was really
strong reason I wanted to see if it
would work and yeah it did it sounds to
me like it was an accident because
they're like it goes like this I'm just
Denise similar to the texture of a
seatbelt it worked really well
on seatbelt and the driver no I got it
fixed it you know what I think about
those seat belt cutters like if you're
in a wreck um roll it and then put it up
what are the odds that like the way you
do you can find the seat belt cutter
no he doesn't like the way I rolled it
no I mean it's fine but no it's not you
can't just criticize a roll and then
re-roll yeah if you roll you roll yeah
okay to Hans is a 10 I don't think so
shut the [__] up wait why is it why is
there only 110. I feel like Hans has got
better looking with I don't know well
they're the three fives and 110. I don't
know red there's only one rounded by
[__]
using his ancient Pennsylvania math
skills for this game should we just play
it out yeah what else are we gonna do
change one of the numbers yeah yeah
change out one of the no you can't
change out a numbered mid games okay we
rolled once there's so many fives change
I rolled a six boys you're rolling eight
I'm [__] okay the 10 what was wrong
with it was you threw it out of the like
the case
did you see how Gareth rolled it
yeah no yeah but
there was nothing wrong with the 10.
there's nothing wrong with the roll I'm
just saying just rolling the the thing
no but just etiquette no not no not that
um there's three fives
six they're supposed to be only two
gotcha so we're missing a 10. uh rolled
it at eight
and we just rolled a six as well
the games have begun boys
try to speak into the mic games have
begun boys scared so worse of that
maybe maybe I should wear the headphones
so I can hear seven oh nice seven
we have more than seven cards
so make some noise if you've been to the
comedy Mothership the newest comedy club
in Austin Texas
[Music]
[Laughter]
how about that damn boys so nobody here
has been to the comedy Mothership the
newest comedy club in Austin Texas no
but I heard you aren't there
there's guidelines right there are
strict guidelines yes and that must be
abided like it's no offense to any other
Comedy Club but you know I wasn't just
gonna like roll up there and be like let
me in
it is a welcoming environment for all
in certain ways yeah right yeah no I
wasn't gonna do that where's how many
Stone do you need for the city
three oh my God David Lucas got panned
really hard I saw on the internet
unfortunately for like some there was
something something comment or whatever
it was yeah and it blew up anyone want
this no you don't want to cancel people
because if you get two woky for the
jokey you go broke
this is very true this is very true I
feel like the mothership is over
scrutiny right now like everybody's
watching it very closely and trying to
get videos and stuff I feel like this
too shall pass really I think it's such
an awesome place for comedy it's so
magical and beautiful and sexual you had
you had sex with the moment was it like
you were making out with some random
with an aliens was it an alien Hans it
was uh nine nine there's might be only
one nine also
it is aliens yeah
built comedy club and it is right in
America and the world a place for art
and Beauty I get it okay right and
Amplified okay I just wanted to make
sure Expose and spread so you got your
dick sucked at the back of the
the mothership is what you're telling
everybody right now where the hell are
my cards that's I think he's playing
onto them that one
uh
I I love the comedy Mothership and so
should you I'm excited for it I can't
wait to go no it'll be exciting to see
it tomorrow well let's just say I hope
it doesn't come to that I feel like I'm
not gonna see it tomorrow I feel like
I'm gonna see the alley behind it which
will be pretty cool right I feel like
Bridge
that's that's the spirit we like to see
I feel like yeah they're just gonna let
us see the alley behind me
and then if we get called up they're
gonna joke about that they're just gonna
yell it's not funny
what's not funny
I think I remember when we went to the
uh the Fox Theater
and when they had the 500th episode oh
the camera and we were behind oh yeah
the Paramount and we were in the alley
behind that no that was right before me
I was wearing my mask I still hadn't
done comedy yet at that point dude you
never did comedy I still hadn't no
really yeah the world was a better place
back then
one less I'm excited I'm excited to
bring him along
I'm gonna make it my own shows oh my
gosh we're doing it dude we're killing
it I got up on that show 500. oh yeah
we're all like oh my God this is a star
now oh
Bridge the big old famous star with
Gareth are you up I don't know am I
that's totally big you know yeah did you
mean she's gonna make any moves Lucas
McCrory went up
eight eight nice he did how did he do he
did amazing he's really funny yeah he
was getting up at the death squad every
week
[Music]
right away after that
okay
he was my first friend
in Austin
are you choke getting choked up about
that yeah they just met last week
there it is also uh you know Luke this I
think one of the first people I also met
him and Dean over at Lucky Duck it was
like on a Wednesday that was the first
open mic I think I went to
um
or at least I tried out yeah would
anyone like to trade wheat for Brick
she's a brick
house
so what's your thoughts on uh
what are your thoughts on the uh State
of the Union speech
I thought you were gonna say the
Ayatollah
um
what is this guy doing over there watch
how you're treating women over there
what is this 12.
hey Ayatollah what you are at all of
these nuts
you can't beat your wife without a
wife's beard where's that card that
gives me the little guidelines of how to
purchase something or what to use to
purchase what oh 12 hell yeah dude oh my
God
give me some Stone I'm sorry that I'm
not skilled we forgot thank you you're a
noob well at least I'm using my
resources I could just be did you just
go ruining the game
you're you're uh you have just this High
chance of winning as anyone
with great power comes great
responsibility because if you beat us
then this shame is harder you win more
emotionally okay this is amazing
why don't you roll
I will I'll try to be better think about
it I'm
so sorry I don't know give me that
cookies
my arms are a little bit shorter in my
defense you know there's I feel like
this is actually no you can reach more
than I can I think so too huh I don't
even know what you are dude I'm Blue
Dude
okay so there's actually Vice made of
they have this series called um the
story of and they do like hit songs from
wherever
um but I'm blue is one of them and they
like go into like how it was made and
the story behind it and it's pretty cool
it was about the Blue Man Group no the
song I'm Blue the uh the band the band
who made that song
how did you get the Blue Man Group out
of that Ridge what the [__] are you
talking about I don't know they have a
weird name what what how did it come to
be
a synopsis
what's a synopsis mean why'd you say it
I don't know
[Music]
so what do you guys think about the use
of the n-word by people that are not
black oh my God are we talking about the
comic we were talking about I gotta P
this uh this guy uh came up to my this
is like two or three in the morning and
um this dude just banged on my door and
he like came out
um or I came out of my house it's like
three in the morning and I'm like what's
going on here I'm done and um
this he's a white he's this white guy he
looks I don't know like my he just I
don't know he just looks like a white
dude and he's just screaming the N word
at me and this is like at [__] two in
the morning I was like dude what's going
on like what I was like you just banged
on my door and he was trying to fight me
and uh he was like I was like you sh you
know why are you screaming the n-word at
me right now and he was just like I'm
Mexican I can say it and I was like I
don't I don't think that's how that
works dude actually my brother's Mexican
you want sheep
um he says it all the time well is he
also black though well I told him I said
you know what yeah maybe you shouldn't
say it so loud I was like you're
screaming the volume that you have a
problem with you don't have any say
about whether he can say it or not oh no
I had a problem with him saying oh that
makes sense you are Mexican and I am
white I I have no power in this
interaction I ended up uh I ended up
telling the guy because he was like
trying to fight me at 3am right in front
of my house and being belligerent and I
was like I'm just stay here I'm gonna go
get my gun and that's how that ended
that conversation
you should get your seatbelt cutter
seven yeah you can't just seat belt cut
your way out of life Gareth I have a
dialogue with these people
I'm adopted yeah
um so yeah it's like my family's wife
I remember that the back you have to get
rid of absolutely but my uh my brother
does say it consistently still to this
day I mean it's whatever yeah
I don't know man like I know I'm not
going to so that's that he was saying it
before I was your white brother says the
N word uh he's he's hispanic and Italian
and yeah it's got some White in there
how old is he he's my age he's 28. was
he adopted too no I knew that was going
to be the next question you have more
than seven cards so that's crazy
what is his excuse does he say I have a
black sister because there's black
people that are lighter than him that
say it so he should be able to too
that's his justification
so he doesn't bring you into it at all
no he doesn't care what I think about it
wait what do you think about it I don't
I don't like it yeah no I don't like it
because he it started like when we were
kids
um that he started saying it and I like
never said it I bet he picks and chooses
like if he's around big black men that
can beat him up I bet he doesn't say it
yeah
thank you so do you think the air force
uh nurtures sort of like a shitty
attitude and some people it nurtures
like a base attitude of like violence
and attack so some people it's bad for
them to be in the military oh well I
mean it's bad for a lot of people to be
in the military that's why I didn't join
it you know it's it you it would
probably be really good for me there's a
lot of people is really good for it like
people that don't have the basics I
can't even like change their bed sheets
and they have like social skills that
are very lacking it gives them like hey
look if you just lift this thing really
high then you can feel happy and good
about yourself and then you can build up
their self-esteem and get them
socialized
I like uh I like that the military would
give me structure that's why I would
want to go you don't want someone that's
in charge of such a big thing for you
exactly you want to be able to do it
yourself 100 I can do that fine my own
are by myself but if there's like a
national battle by himself like in Korea
everyone has to join the military
and I think that's bad but I think it's
good in some ways
isn't that the same thing for like
Israel or something yeah but they're
like all for it
anyway I don't know what's really going
on over in the Middle East but uh you
know the other Israelis are all for
military stuff they're all for getting
at it they're all for it dude that's all
I know
dude I'm gonna have a what's it called
hit on me violence is a cool thing if
you're bored eight yeah you're gonna
have this seat belt cutter company no
dude what what's uh
what's it called whenever the Ayatollah
puts a hit out on you
a fatwa dude yeah I'm making a photo
thank you an eight was rolled thank you
oh nice wow
that's how you know it's decided
you all right
oh it's a happy one
but you know um
dude if I had a fart while I put on me
you've had a fall tour put on me I'm
about to fart while on your face I think
I would uh
straight up just go to the dead I would
go to the middle of nowhere I mean what
would happen if y'all got out of here
how would y'all deal with that situation
that'd be all right like I'd get my
Shooters out
I can't do [__] here you go
I just got all these cards wasted away
what did you roll game eight sir what is
your Royal Janisha
a six
really no
12.
00 I just say no I do wait what what
because it's too late
oh wait that's fine
I don't know if I was trying to pull why
are there two twelves
damn it rich Ridge I didn't do that it
was you no put the numbers now and the
nines are next to each other no I didn't
put the numbers you put the numbers down
like that
I put two eights next to each other yeah
oh no scared getting drunk no I'm not
drunk you can't get drunk off a beer
that's scientifically impossible Gareth
is what George Bush sounded like when he
decided to invade Iraq oh my God what a
cool guy I'm gonna steal from
uh jamisha
George Bush say what you want that dude
was hilarious like was that one thing he
was talking about
um where he was like uh
say what you would what oh I can't
remember it's like every other word was
like a mistake uh for like a really
basic saying I can't remember what that
was do you all know what I'm talking
about
I'm pretty young so like I don't
remember bush
yeah how old are you rich you're 25
right uh-huh
I really I don't get I don't know when
did that happen
he's our president in 2000 and 2000
there's no three is there
yeah there's no way
did you make sure you got wheat
some people call it hay and some people
call it wheat it's wheat it's yellow
it's probably straw
yeah dude so last night was a lot of fun
I'm really excited for the rest of South
by Thundercats tomorrow
and uh there's a lot more going on
that like just it's going it's happening
this is what this is reminding me of uh
and we're like going to see that band
last night was like old Austin oh it
made me feel like um
what I think you should redo it yeah
that's a redo okay sorry I was
fell off I wasn't trying to pull some
[__] anything uh he was gonna shank me
over them
yeah I think on Tuesday I'm gonna try to
go see Joe DeRosa at the creek
Joe DeRosa that's gonna be a good one
yeah he's there tomorrow doing this
sandwich thing and
hits it was so funny on kill Tony
he made the one joke about the irony
store that didn't work oh yeah and then
every comic could be like Tony yeah this
guy looks like he shops at the irony
store
[Laughter]
uh yeah he was special
very good he offered me 20 off a sub if
I I'm ever in New York
so I've got a hold of him a Subway
a sub he owns
he owns it
yeah
Delicatessen I don't know what they oh
no yeah
that's so funny Joe De Rosa owns a
bodega yeah oh I heard those subs are
good too yeah like I heard they're like
I'm excited to do that whenever I go to
[__] New York next time yeah all
right for wait so I'm gonna is that are
you done before yeah I'm done okay
is this your first time you've played
before Oh my God
[Music]
I used to play with my friends in
Maryland we played together they taught
me how to play and yeah I've played a
few times with you guys I just like
always sort of she was adopted by white
people I was not adopted by white people
ten oh we got ten so do you think I mean
that could be the you know pretty bad
situations
my family you're a fan what about my my
My adoptive family dude you don't have
an adopted family no I do okay but then
what what was what were you saying about
them I was gonna say that the adopted
family
they
uh they hate me just like most
almost ever so it could be worse dude
what I'm saying does that make sense no
I'm not nobody knows what you're talking
about you're really bad at telling
stories
right now for no reason I'm making [__]
up right now
but if I did they would hate me throwing
it out there dude it's like the worst
version of theobon yeah
no I'll hate you yeah that's exactly it
yours are you going 10 10 uh yeah I'm
done there's nothing I can do here I
have nothing I mean I think white
families are great
most time
yeah no like my mom like ended up
remarrying and then she married a white
man and he had these three white kids
and then then I lived with white people
for
a while
what people do you think it's so that's
where like the white part of my jokes
come in and then the rest of it's
mexican and italian
well those are pretty American that's
America that's a neopolitan mix of
America yeah what age did she remarry
um she was I mean what age were you well
I was
I think like 22 or 23. my dad cheated on
her uh and then long story short she
ended up in a relationship with my dad
and the woman that he cheated on her
with and so they were in this it was
this Austin Texas no this was in
Maryland what how did I think that stuff
I don't call it Maryland for nothing
yeah and so then yeah they were together
for a while and then my parents got
divorced and then my dad married that
one which parents all three of them
there's a trifecta of divorce uh yeah
yeah they were gonna like they were she
was gonna move into the house and
everything
um six maybe like a year and a half and
then maybe like a good time were they in
their like 40s yeah yeah so it was like
a midlife crisis yeah for sure I'm
diagnosing stupid midlife [__] and
yeah so my dad married her and then
moved to Guam with her so that was cool
would anyone like this did it damage
your childhood no because you said you
were 22. I weren't hitting questions
well actually no I was 19 when he he
cheated on my mom and then yeah I think
it was a few years later that she
remarried I didn't go to I went to her
wedding but I wasn't invited oh sorry no
it's fine it's just fun it's funny
because you guys hate me
I'm not sorry that your dad cheated on
your mom and then and that's tried to
get your mom to [__] your other mom no
they did it wasn't like relationship
I don't know that sounds kind of awesome
to me
I don't know how to take this story but
she was like when that when they did it
she had like just turned 30 or something
um your mom's only eight years older
than you
oh the other lady the other lady I was
like what
is that how is that really stopped at me
like so she could be any age she would
be younger yeah I would say don't start
off a trifecta relationship by cheating
because that sets a bad tone for the
rest of the thing and it shouldn't be
done at a weakness it should be done out
of strength because those things are
hard and if you start with like you know
betrayal and pain then it's like it's
gonna be some weird thing it's gonna be
hard times giving advice on three-way
relationships everybody uh yeah that was
pretty yeah I actually thought that was
pretty good that's pretty good advice
yeah to people starting like yeah I've
never done it I'm just no you shouldn't
start off by cheating on on your wife
you should start off by like oh yo let's
go find a little side little side thing
at the I'm absolutely gonna have a wife
and then cheat on it it's like let me do
17 shots of alcohol and then try doing a
tightrope act yeah
I'm gonna have like three wives at least
I'm not even in my I haven't even had
one yet surrounded by [__] no not
even non-consensually I had six
here we go some people are into that
though oh
my God
all right here we go nine
someone roll a goddamn seven you have
nothing [__] Jesus Christ this last
one was a six
actually and this one's a nine
three six nine damn do we all still have
two points except for Ridge
not anymore [__] oh my God I'm out of
here
right in the middle of my settlement
oh watch where you go
I'll tell you
[Laughter]
what were you is that did you say how
dare you because you're wearing the Dare
shirt yeah did you know that shirt is
new his dare shirt yeah I brought it I
bought it ironically
say something
cool it's up here it's a dare shirt it's
like an actual dare shirt it's an
awesome logo like if you're wearing a
logo you might as well wear a symbol of
your enemies failures on your torso yeah
when they came to our school that was a
total fail for them we just all bought
if I wrote something yeah to go smoke
weed with later on hey let's go buy some
shirts to smoke weed with
that age
like because they're always daring each
other to do [__] I double dog dare you
double dog yeah double dog dare and
they're they read dare and they're like
bet
let's go [__] it is
terrible that's why they're all punked
and jacked ass they're all like crazy
little Rebels they just do the opposite
of whatever you tell them because
they're simple oh God
oh my gosh
this is not going well for me guys it's
all right you're good
yo this board is [__] I don't know
what I was thinking the numbers you put
down yeah
that is not what was not a good idea
definitely not
oops hey it happens
I've got it
don't don't make that face I've got it
not telling my trauma story now
four four
oh my God how do y'all feel about uh
Street takeovers what was that
did you hear the whistle yeah it sounded
like metal though I think I did
something squeaking
no
I don't know
holy [__] fly crossing over into the
other life it's like
which what you've been up to dude are
you still working with that farm or
whatever down every now and then what do
you do whenever you're taking care of
animals you like put your hand in a
cow's [__] or like what's going on
what's up sometimes you gotta yeah
is that what they hired you to do
because sometimes hey can you stick your
hand in this cow's [__]
better that goes dude uh if it needs it
I mean it
and it's always needing it isn't it rich
[Laughter]
hey Rich knows what I'm talking about
the baby cow's mouths dude
oh my God Jimmy shit's fine I'll be fine
wait hold on does anybody have a sheep I
am offering a wood for a sheet
here you go I don't know why I did that
[__] up so bad guys
no no no don't sing that song
Oh Baby who's hungry
yo let's get some of the words dude
Gareth order says some pizza oh that
sounds like a plan okay it sounds like a
plan uh we can get uh there's a couple
different really good pies around here
I don't like I don't want like a pie I
want pizza
get the [__] out of your pizza pie get
the [__] out of here Rich it's a pizza
pie
Dude tell them that we're recording a
live podcast and we will shout them out
and we'll get free pizza hell no we're
not gonna tell them no try it try it see
what happens okay I got some advertising
use your whiteness for good yeah
not evil hey man I don't yeah that's the
problem
using your whiteness for evil the evil
I don't think I don't think Gary's evil
at all no no no no I don't I think it's
all out there like no you're not adding
anything oh wait I have this settlement
I'm anti-inter now in the right place
I mean we could always take away his
food and his oh yeah you take away my
food dude
immediately
if you're gonna take away my rights yeah
you can place it there did you put down
the right oh dude have you have y'all
watched The Last of Us and you guys have
y'all watched The Last of Us no I've
only watched this is us
[Music]
is that a is that a like a [__] thank
you huh I appreciate that this is us
this is us that was a good show
it's about this black kid that was
adopted by a white family oh that's
awesome and that's how it was presented
to me when someone they were like you
were adopted by white people right did
have you watched this show you gotta
watch that show now
what was your experience I know you know
what type of white phone did you see did
it seem accurate no there's um not lying
when I say there 10.
Italian and Mexican
and then when my it was when my mom
remarried the white people didn't seem
accurate so like they're pretty spicy
does it seem accurate yeah oh yeah
they're not like English no
no they're kind of suburbate
Gareth are you done uh no Center I got a
lot to do I think so militaries
I'm sorry what happened man what do you
all want for pizza I'm just gonna do
plain cheese and pepperoni right
this sausage what is the okay here's a
good question what is the debate
whenever you have a group of people for
pizza you just go pepperoni and cheese
right just to not like or a sausage a
sauce sauce I don't agree with sausage
sometimes when you don't know what kind
of sausage they're using what about
barbecue chicken no now you're getting
zany because if you have a group of
people we all have to agree to this and
people don't like barbecue chicken oh
okay well no people do like barbecue
chicken but now some people don't
like wait does does Ridge do you like
barbecue chicken pizza let's see yes or
no
wait were you guys arguing about it no
no no I'm not arguing we're talking
about when you're in a group of people
what you buy for pizza is cheese and
pepperoni so there's no goddamn
pandemonium he's saying that some people
don't like or not everybody likes uh
everyone is trying to avoid pandemonium
oh dude I'm trying to avoid the
pandemonium dude some people want to
take risks and live life not just so all
I hear is you want to do a basic cheese
and pepperoni and Hans wants to do
barbecue no no yes okay because cheese
and pepperoni is good if the pizza is
good but the cheese if the pizza's flat
well this we're getting it from a good
spot I'm going to Home Slice I'm gonna
get it from home slice so and I like
some more [__] on it and since I don't
know where it's from I would just go
first I like beep we beep that out
no free sponsors yeah oh I mean I wish
home slide that's like maybe the best
pizza in Austin so be right up there I'm
so sorry I'm still going
to trade this in hey can you order some
pizza guys
yo home slice can you uh
home is where the home slices
home skillet
scale it isn't this so much better
because if you don't have the little
things incredibly better the cards get
everywhere it's very nice actually I
have to send my friends a picture of
this because this is and these are cheap
too so these are really expensive if you
buy Like official Katan card holders but
if you got these these are just business
card holders they're like 15 bucks
I don't like how it's vertical it's kind
of annoying but Han's throwing out more
tips for the people
I just like facts
and then what else effects are better
than feelings
that's it I have my turn here you go
order the pizza
you call me a [__] [__] 10. whoa whoa
relax
oh it's all fun and games this is such a
slow whoa
go ahead Ridge
because we're all like a disaster in
some way shape or form
Gareth has a seat belt cut in his shirt
I don't know how to roll the dice what a
bad decision I made but there's no
lemons Hans on on a [__] fly mission
oh my god dude all right over there
there's a fly right there the the Y the
wire for my mic keeps touching me and I
keep thinking it's like a fly crawling
on me yeah dude
I'm tripping I've been smoking
it's a crazy world that we have to share
with flies there's creatures every every
scale down nine who the hell put this
here man
we've only rolled a five once and that's
pissing me off I'll tell you what I
think it's been rolled more than that
I'll tell you what
I think so because I have a five and I
have been getting stuck
once yeah there's three fives we're all
next to a five
[Laughter]
yo dude no remember when I saw you at
the creek and like what's up Hans and I
was like what's up jamish
did I get mad at you I feel like I I
might have been like what Jimmy
I was going through this phase where I
was giving everyone a nickname just so I
could oh
everyone
what's up I'm glad you made note of that
moment in our friendship
what are the shortening of your name
what'd you think about it afterwards did
you invite me after that jamish is like
a masterpiece it might be the best one
that I've come up with I
other people have also I wouldn't call
it a masterpiece man what the hell
that is so funny go or order pizza I'm
[__] if you would like you can call
me jamish if you would like to take a
second I'd like that I did it once three
I like that it was just something wait
who's green James
it's just not a real nickname oh damn
how did you oh you want to trade torn
down
you got a sheep dude I know you're a
herder you're a farmer I got Stone and I
got brick so what do you want man brick
brick it is sir thank you very much
this is how we do business boys all
right here you go Hans
nine Gareth order pizza oh
[Music]
I don't think it's ever gonna get
ordered
man it's coming it's coming you have to
worry about it
huh you're done oh DiGiorno dude
I'm not a sponsor God damn it with the
nines you know DiGiorno is also pretty
bad but at 2 A.M that [__] slash I don't
take wheat right because give me a
DiGiorno pizza at 2AM see what happens
let's see all right doordash doordash is
filled with a bunch of ratchet ass
[__] drivers
oh yeah who don't know
I'm also a door Dasher so
self-defense would you just put yourself
down because it's filled with a bunch of
ratchet ass
you never meet them whoa yeah they're
all crackheads every time that's what I
say about it oh my God HR departments
across the country every time I get a
lot of kids every time we're gonna like
fly a space shooter or something like
don't you think so what do you think
we're in the podcast
we are man this place has really come
together Hans I love it it's great dude
there's like these things on the wall
for a little while the curtains with the
red curtains awesome very good I know
it's the classic the curtains with the
red curtains hey shut the [__] up rich
don't mock me all right
uh opens his mouth
I do I do it it's just a feeling it's
amazing he can smell
see okay uh home slice guys that's where
yeah let's see it
um
so what do you think about how long it
took to set up
uh I was pretty disappointed
the kitten game because Hans was like
firm on be here in 30. I was like can
you be here in 30 minutes and you're
like yes yes what's the address yeah but
then I found it I sent you the address
and then you were like I'm here yeah but
regardless of all that
we didn't start until like an hour and a
half until after I showed up after he
showed up after I showed up oh yeah
but he was like so Firma like be here in
30 and I was just like I didn't say be
here in 30. I said can you and then uh
you were like what's the address so I
was like oh she has a left in the group
chat you said 30 minutes and then to me
you said 30 minutes and so in my head I
was like okay I'm gonna get there in 30
minutes I thought that was like the
right you did because we had a great
conversation and you didn't have to stay
at that stupid mic that you were at yeah
that mic was were you at the one at like
2 30. yeah with the piano have you been
there oh I love that one
I know it was no it wasn't bad I just
had to leave
well you're welcome I gave you a safe
space Oh yeah this has been such a safe
space
um the Flies love black people and um
and uh okay can I put this a phone
charger at least there's no piano did
you order the pizza I'm trying I need a
phone truck why I need a phone charger
my phone's about to die I bet I could
order a piece of pizza so fast it's
downstairs no I'm trying to order from a
specific one but I don't I don't just
eat pizza okay I have to have good pizza
Rich this is an acquirement of mine cool
rats I have the one app one bite app no
the slice app
okay
um
the slice app what is that what's a
slice app it's for Just Pizza it's just
for pizzas pizza what the [__] are you
serious is that a thing yes it's really
popular oh my God in the Amish community
let's get out of here dude what are you
doing man what are you doing away from
what do they call what are the what is
the on is it a what is it a group is it
is what is the animation is it just the
Amish community
it's a religion I saw uh
I went and saw women talking and I fell
asleep
[Laughter]
did you did you watch how did you feel
about that take on women I didn't watch
oh any of that I don't know I don't know
what the it is a very serious movie it
is a very serious movie yeah and it was
really good apparently can I um can I
say some things
may I speak okay can I uh hey does
anybody have like some stone for some
wood
you're gonna you want Stone I want Stone
looking for or no I want Stone giving
wood
I want stone I have two Woods you're
giving wood two wood for once two wood
for one stone yeah give me that [__]
right now there it is we out here
wheeling and I'm dealing
all right
um are we all tied at three
I'm looking I'm looking for some sheep
some sheep
for uh two wheat
you'll give two weeks I'll give two
wheat
for a sheep
I'll give a wheat and a wood for a sheep
yeah
I'll give uh oh wait is it charging
and I'm gonna get it done
did you get the pizza I'm ordering it as
we speak my man are you gonna get enough
I'm gonna get a large pizza is do they
have breadsticks there uh no they have
incredible well actually they do do you
want breadsticks or do you want wings or
what are y'all thinking
how's this going down right now we got
to make this up dude we gotta figure out
this lunch let's get barbecue chicken
Who's down
they don't have a barbecue chicken at
home slice did
they have barbecue no it's amazing it's
a new word piece of barbecue get out of
here dude what are you doing
who doesn't love Barbecue on their Pizza
jamisha has five people it's a party on
your pizza dude
the hell oh
End of the Road
um we got the longest road card
go ahead and give that to her I have it
uh
okay I'm done that's the Army thank you
how'd you like that roll guys no okay
keep it I got a nine I hate you so much
dude why has this been here for so long
because nobody rolled a seven nope yeah
that's what that means it's good it
would be really good if this was that
game
um puts a game at the casino where you
throw the dice and don't want to roll a
seven
craps you ever play craps no my mom does
she she does yeah I don't understand it
at the casino if she calls it the Nino
the video
yeah she has a childish relationship to
gambling
my uh
my uncle won like 20K of craps I don't
believe you with like 200 bucks dude
it's just like the Nicholas I don't
believe you immediately
Nick Cage did that [__] one time I don't
I don't we're done
prove it
did he claim it on his taxes no
it was uh it was uh it was in the
Bahamas man it was uh what was that 12.
and like uh Saint Barts or seven seven
oh [__]
pounds I'm good
I'm good I'm seven dude okay
yeah no uh
uh
what was this oh seven move that [__]
you [__] [__] come on no I'm
thinking I'm thinking I'm thinking
are you [__] kidding me dude all
right what's wrong with you what are you
doing are you serious on it why because
it it blocks it completely blocks
there's no [__] he has no access to
the stone I have no access this year
already has no access to she had none of
12. yeah
absolutely no accesses you took away
point zero one percent chance dude she
has yeah we're all tied does anyone want
um
two week for a break
[__] I don't have a brick no
I'm doing a three for one trade because
I'm on a port
yes unimportant yo so within I think
Hans gave up on like um
taking this game seriously because
the numbers are [__] up
that am I right what do you mean I'm
just playing the game this is what it
looks like yeah stay here for most of it
Ridge what the [__] is that supposed to
mean I'm waiting for my numbers to roll
it's called Katan thank you uh on this
tour the tour
the eight yeah and no I understood I
just it took me the second time I got it
is very thoughtful
do you have a white friend no that was
what my family watched that's awesome
that's multiple way friends
what was there who was their favorite
out of all of them was it Larry or Jeff
oh of course like between it was
probably Larry but definitely between
Jeff and Larry dude I mean they're all
good man so I don't have nothing who's
number three
who's number three
uh it's wrong white man oh and then Jim
who else was it Jim Ingle billing ball
yeah
Billy involved dude yeah it was a good
it was a good set but they had a they
had a time man and uh Jeff Foxworthy was
the nerd Larry the Cable Guy was just a
pure comedy idiot like Uncle
uncle's a cool guy Ron was the artistic
Merit of the group he was like the
command of the most respect and Bill
Engvall was like the all-around pinch
hitter he could do all of it yeah yeah
absolutely
oh
if it takes longer than 30 minutes to
order the pizza he has to buy all of it
no [__] off all right I'm gonna set a
timer I'm not doing that all right all
right all right all right set a timer
I'm putting in there right now I'm
putting in the address I'm putting in
the [__] address two hours from now
guys hold on okay I'm putting in the
address just hold on
sucks that I did this already why is it
coming Vancouver
what the hell
Vancouver this is what it's saying
I love the blue car guys that's my goal
and they
uh let's see okay awesome what was one
of you Matt be a redneck you might be a
redneck if your family tree does not
have any more limbs I liked how you said
which the which is the one and then you
started how he starts literally every
joke yeah that's so
doesn't Fork
you might be a redneck if you
cars are held up with cinder blocks in
the front yard
what the hell dude
what the hell what's happening my eyes
what's going on what the hell
fly pie
she slide down this is like a terrarium
for flies this place gets warm the
windows are all here they have they
hatch here they breed here why did we
Garrett you have to go now sorry I'm
ordering the [__] Pizza what do you
want from me I can only do one thing at
once hold on no yeah I'm done I can't do
anything
for
four
anyone want brick
for wood I'll break you up yes thank you
oh my god dude
what toppings are you ordering
cheese and and sausage or do you want me
to do pepperoni I'm doing pepperoni so
there's no matters
okay cheese and sausage
or pepperoni sausage yeah
what if I just ordered an hlg pizza
right now
[Music]
it's [__] up that was my best uh
SpongeBob reference thank you
okay so
um
anything else sides what are we doing we
gotta agree upon something I was
thinking of one side right one side they
have uh garlic knots buffalo wings or
salad
I like garlic I mean I guess we're nine
what the [__] is with these nines garlic
I don't understand
nine Gareth
yo hold on hold on
oh sorry
25 minutes
two this is like what was that wasn't
there a whole movie based on what did
you just say something in French I said
two hours later
I thought later
oh that's definitely
okay
um
do you think SpongeBob was the last
great child's show kids show
because after that there hasn't been
really that great or are we just not
kids anymore Pokemon was great so we
don't know what the good child shows are
but that crossed over to adults what's
the last kids show to cross over to
adults oh that's true but we also don't
have SpongeBob but like we also don't
have the kids and that's what we're
talking about you idiot yeah Squidward
has to be like the number one thing
Squidward as a character on SpongeBob is
there any other show that crossed over
to adults
your Cowardly Dog
like that was not a kid's show exactly
man but it was shut the [__] it was a
cartoon I'm looking for some Stone I'm
willing to trade a wood for the stone
Lord
I am willing to trade a wood for a stone
I'm willing to trade a wood and a hay
for a stone no
wood and hay for stone I am willing to
trade
a brick and a hay for sale someone's
gonna trade you for the stone man
I am willing to trade yeah it would and
a brick first stone
I am willing to trade no one wants to
trade
see see that's why I blocked your stone
well I know that had nothing to do with
it I still ask though
true
I wish you I wish you could make it
covering the 12 did nothing so far what
if you could block a train
yeah you want to be America
can we just block trades yeah don't
trade with Cuba because I don't like
that they
didn't let us invade them
you know the Cuba used to be a like a
sugar Plantation for America yeah I am
looking for a sheep where are we used to
I have a vacation I'm willing to trade
it a week for a sheep
all righty okay I've ordered the pizza
boys
gonna be here in [__] an hour to
purchase a settlement it'll probably get
it over here when we're done perfect
settlement I was trying to like sand it
through like I gotta I just gotta maybe
people wanted to pay for our pizza
I got a pizza to salad
um right now you got a salad
Greek yeah what the hell what's the why
is it so that's like the worst thing you
could have picked what
you don't know what you're talking about
well I only did because you told me to
and we didn't talk about that are you
you're upset right now well you can't
build this out without a road and you
can't build a road but you can't build a
road
so you should build a road instead of a
settlement and the way for wooden brick
for another turn what's on a Greek salad
Okay so
Greek salad traditionally it's actually
just cheese and like olive oil and and
and olives like that's what do you think
about this side he's choosing the side
to be a salad uh
that's not the most
fun food to eat
okay so should I get should I have
gotten Buffalo or should I get buffalo
wings too or something like what do you
want from me man that's good we're
eating pizza
I don't have to order two things you can
eat the salad if you wanted to eat salad
you can eat salad oh I'm gonna eat the
[__] out of that salad you don't get any
pizza you have to eat all this out I
would eat that [__] whole salad I
think it's incredible it's a great salad
are you done James
um
yeah what do you want from me
where's that Flock of Seagulls is that
the name of that band
four
break Matt okay for um what the [__] is
that
oh yes that's what I needed actually
here we go
all right the Lord is always on time
Gareth
what the Lord is always on time
so do you think America is done as
[Laughter]
all right as a cultural force and as a
superpower no yeah dude China's gonna
take over for sure no I don't give a
[__] we're trying what they're doing in
China
I'll give a [__] about China dog don't
you think it's like I do want to
inherently flawed it's like just not
gonna lead anywhere
China dead end no America
it's like
there's a flaw in its programming yeah
we made too many mistakes yeah and we we
can't fix it we're too stubborn yeah
we're too deep into it so yeah there's I
have no faith for yeah this is I'm zero
it was a good run
well I mean like we can go out with the
bangs just make a big mess this is a
bomb shelter correct
this is it's the opposite it's at the
top of the house
look we're gonna have to start breeding
flies we're teaching them
uh 12. yes [__] yeah
hey I want sprick
get out of here get out of here dude I
want sheep
absolutely not
I get four for one secret don't trade
with Hans he's sneaky as [__] he's
always planning something okay that's
probably a good thing to always be
planning something yeah five oh my God
that's what I'm talking about dude
yeah
I'll trade uh to
forests that's a Brian for a um
we didn't even notice oh really yeah
no you're good man I thought I heard
screaming earlier that was the only
thing yeah yeah that was it uh I don't
know like 20 minutes ago but I was like
oh I heard that too I thought it was a
sign though yeah it wasn't nothing
oh yeah oh well maybe it's the people
next door dude I don't know maybe there
was a murder
dude that would be sick they could be
see it having another kid you too dude
let's see okay so what do you think
about this podcast Studio isn't it
I told you this already yeah
sorry it took so long to set up for
wheat
what the [__] dude you're slipping well
you came and then we started pretty much
the
um I like these little things back here
so I'm sad those are gone they're still
there and if you want the criticism I
wish the curtains were a little less
wrinkly
you want me to iron curtains that may be
those lights no she does make a very
good point these are [__] wrinkly and
[__] if we're gonna do
we can find
care of the flag problem because when
that one with that blue light
look I'm just saying dude where are the
zappers like they they said constantly
they start smoking and they catch on
fire sometimes they like saying that
that's pretty cool you get one of those
in Louisiana you can make a killing four
holy [__] no pun intended
a killing
um
um so guy yeah just listen guys the
curtains look worse in person than you
on camera so you're not getting it as
bad they are a little cheap they look
like
should we get ice cream too or am I just
being really fat right now it's gonna
come in wait did you order it yeah you
ordered the home slice right yeah it's
ordered it's coming they said it's gonna
be here about nine o'clock eight o'clock
so what time is it 8 30. you said the
curtains are wrinkly because I just got
them this is the first grand opening
and if you thought that setup took long
wait till I'm right ironing curtains
um but yeah currently we have to iron
them one time I'm gonna iron them I
might not even iron them I might steam
them that's a good idea too just yeah
get the wrinkles out of them in a few
yeah I mean if you like care about it
they might look cheap but I think they
look good on camera
like if you feel them they feel really
nice they just look like [__]
um that's the worst combination that's
tough good curtains that look like [__]
because then No One's Gonna appreciate
like this is like durable material not
that you need that like here you could
have gotten away with something why is
it my turn right something else uh no
where do I go to buy curtains where do I
go to never you got to order them on
Amazon dude that's the world we live on
Jeff Bezos I want to go to some woman's
Curtain Shop whoa I bet you they have
those here in Austin yeah so there's
something like old lady yeah when I
moved the lady that had curtains
why the [__] are you talking about
curtains like this right now you think
this is into entertaining she's sort of
like creative memory stuff she was a
hoarder it was horrible this is uh
M M's album cover and
2000 what was it three I don't know when
that album came out
so the FCC won't let me be or let me be
means oh and he's on stage
MTV he's sitting on the stage
what well I'll do it Eminem was the man
we should have another we should have
another he had a [__] moment
anybody starts yelling we should have
another scoreboard for how many beers
drank
oh I'm sorry but Garrett's on like
uh six well at least there's just here
I'm just here I had the worst Denny's in
my life today I never thought Denny's
could be that bad I got up and I was
like holy [__] it's two o'clock what am
I doing
I deal with some family [__] and uh
yeah right after that and then Hans was
like yo let's play Katan I was like
[__] finally 30 minutes
it's been a million years
good to see you too Hans yeah how's
traveling the world baby yeah
I was gonna ask you the same [__] dude I
think there might be some in my car but
I gotta
go check them
yeah yeah
um
well yeah I mean I wanted to play Catan
unfortunately I've been traveling the
world selling out comedy clubs
having a great time I'm so happy for you
man couldn't be happier for you living
the dream what the [__] okay oh yeah I
was making my doing exactly what I want
to do for the rest of my life [__]
[__] already
I have been in a relationship as well
that has been that that is awesome I was
gonna say hi to you the other night it
looked like you were a little bit busy
in the back of the creek in the cave
yeah there was this like two to three
nights ago always a little bit I had a
fit I had a I like women I like dating I
like sex and now that I can do it I do
it
making up for the last time yeah you did
dude that's what you're doing are you
done
yeah yeah I mean I like trying to get
dating and attention I'm trying to keep
that keep that spark of dating alive
because I could easily hate dating and
like be like oh I hate people but I
think it's good to be around with other
people hey this is why I love you Hans
you you set things into perspective it's
also why I think comedians are awesome
people people are gonna say oh this was
a racist thing or this was sexist or
whatever but every comic is just
comedians are just people that are
really open
I'm saying that well Jesus Christ
jamisha why don't you let me finish
talking I was gonna say that comedians
are good people like all heartedly
around like if you meet and talk to
somebody most of the time what do you
think oh who
you don't think so Ridge okay yeah you
have examples right for what wood wrap
for wood yeah
you'll know John heft
John Heff looks like he tucks his dick
between his legs and says would you [__]
me and then goes I wouldn't
um nothing there does anyone have wheat
no no response to that all right
I have Rock you're doing jokes Gareth
yeah there's a roaster right on him
thanks you [__]
Garrett do you have wheat uh I do what
do you want rock you want sheep
give me that sheep Doug oh my God I
can't believe you're trading after Han's
ass like I know what I'm doing okay
he knows how to he knows how to talk to
me jamisha
it just went on for so long I thought
you were just trying not to give him
weed I'm trying to I'm trying to run
bits about John half that [__] guy
that looks like a TGIF manager that goes
all right guys we're gonna have a great
day today
it's great if you're on stage
and it's like oh that makes sense it's
funny but it's not like a truism about
who he is it's just like an act out
seven right
[__] well I'm trying to get gauge y'all
because I'm I'm helping out whoever it's
roasting
I'm trying to help you can you not Gage
us can you just be in the moment in
natural and just have an honest
conversation instead of us oh my God to
have a better set later you made me seem
like such a white devil dude what the
hell man I'm not a user or an abuser
just have a normal coverage this is a
question I got yesterday from a white
person
um they were like do you prefer
white man or white boy like what does
what sounds better Nick Roche asked me
this he was like white man boy would you
rather wow a man or a white boy
I don't like it when anybody calls me he
asked who that me
what what sounds better white man or
white boy
wait man
that's what I thought
are you done would you rather be called
a white man or a white boy
I wouldn't I would not want to be called
a boy I think being called a boy is
[__] what about a fuckboy
you know what that's actually I I'd like
that because sometimes I am a third
white boy you [__] that white boy
Toyota
that [__] boy you know a girl
oh hell yeah yeah no I definitely come
off as a [__] boy sometimes yeah that's
for sure you come off as a suck my dick
boy all right girl just go high I'll
trade this for come off it's a [__] boy
wait wait no wait oh wait what wait wait
wait wait no no no no no no no no no
get out of here dude it's good but I
can't
so good it hurts so good it hurts
hey I've had some pretty good rolls oh
my God
damn it with the nine yeah you have a
knife you have the most nines you have a
nine two hunts don't you
I don't
know
you're wrong once again what gun do you
have
uh Shadow systems mr920l
what what the [__] did you just say
right now Shadow systems mr920l I can
take two resources how's your uh flying
your drone I crashed it into a parking
garage is it broken now it's a little
broken yeah what the [__] man what
happened
it just kept going forward
so I was like go right go left go left
and then I was like what's good what's
it doing now it's drifting were you
drinking and flying your drone
no it was just like it kept going sorted
out when you first started out it's not
that responsive
it's annoying huh I don't know what it
is it's just like not very communicated
yeah
autopilot takes over this should be a
fine does anyone have a sheet I am
willing to trade a wood I'll take a
wheat it's dangerous
yeah I hit the side of it by the stone
spent all night looking for it
oh no couldn't find it I'm sorry I
didn't mean to bring up a bad night dude
that sounds awesome it's Friday night
this Friday night yeah Saturday morning
I woke up and I went to look for it was
right there in the tree right by the
entrance oh man how did I miss this last
night it was right there it's just
hanging there because you weren't drunk
I wasn't that drunk I spent like two
hours looking for it and then I went
back the next day and found it
but the battery was uh Missing the
battery somebody stole the battery I
don't think so I think it just fell away
yeah maybe it fell out oh probably fell
out I don't know where it is but so when
you go to other cities what do you do
[__]
he said tutu
it's
all right yo guys I need a brick who
wants to trade Gareth for Brick
come on
come on guys
somebody come on though please
what do you think about the Austin
comedy I'm done what do I think about
the Austin comedy scene 12. I am
enjoying myself so far I don't have
anything to compare it to because well
what do you think in general just do you
like it or no yeah I like it I like it
and I like a lot of uh
people I've met and a lot of the
opportunities I've gotten and yeah I'm
having a lot of fun
seven I think it's an amazing scene yeah
everyone came here to party because we
came here from whatever during the
pandemic and we're like we're all gonna
meet here and cough on each other
and everyone who wanted to take that
risk game here so there's like a party
atmosphere
like most comedy scenes aren't like this
most comedy scenes people don't party
like this
but they just kind of live their lives
right like they have families shut the
[__] up
what the [__] does that even mean you
[__] loser shut your goddamn mouth
Ridge I think it's a very young scene
too like other scenes are older
comedians yeah yeah that's it that's a
lot of babies the older crowd's getting
into it though
yeah it takes a lot more to move when
you're old
um I feel like I see older people at
Mike's now and you know trying to
anybody willing to give up actually
doing it it's cool yeah there's like
seven comedy clubs in downtown Austin
yeah it's nuts
we have five large ones too got Cap City
you have now you have the of course
mother [__] you have uh the creek in the
cave you have Sunset Strip and uh I'm
missing one I know I am
yeah no well there's a there's a fifth
one I think the big one's clearly there
were
um Cap City
cab City Creek in the cave Mothership
Vulcan Vulcan there it is so five those
are the five they're very large venues
and I've seen so many good shows too at
these venues as well it's ridiculous
yeah and these comedy audiences are
seeing this comedy and then they're
going out into the world with that idea
of what comedy is in their head and it
makes them more likely to come to
another show smaller shows
and it makes the city like more vibrant
people are communicating and talking to
each other and observing things about
the city
and it's like good to be self-aware and
to laugh about it and to have like the
best observations about the city praised
and rewarded but that's what Austin's
always been about it's been about
looking and finding people just in
general it gives it gives people an
opportunity to do their art that's why
so many good artists in every genre have
made it here and there's a lot of people
are just open to listening to that [__]
but
um you know it's a mix too right you
still are in Texas even though this is
Austin but
there's uh the culmination and
everybody's acceptance is here and the
capital like there's politics
everybody's trying to tell us and racism
and anger and violence well racism Focus
sucks but I don't know whatever I think
uh racism now I think about how the NFL
painted in racism into the back of the
end zone like that was like gonna do
something there like that was there that
was their response what it does is it
bothers the right people
if you're bothered by that then you're
an idiot I think that I'm not bothered
by it but it's their response to how
they reacted to like Colin Kaepernick
and all these other big situations like
I think that's great I think it's like
yes that is something that we should do
eight probably we should do that
but yeah no I mean it's like very simple
and very like you know like uh not that
not that uh
not not intellectually deep but it's
like that's what sports is it's like
it's just feelings and emotions so it's
like why don't you use feelings to stop
racism
well there's just like so much hypocrisy
with the NFL but that's just uh one of
those things but in general like taxes
you know it's always going to be a good
old boy state
it's what it is for
and that's like the big issue I would
say in the capital too I want sheep
I think it's I want to hear what jamisha
says well you think about it last week
and racism in the end zones at the
football games I don't I don't care
I don't
I don't care that's not that I don't
care about racism
I just don't care what they choose to do
with the end zones
exactly that's the point never thought
and it's so
yeah I just yeah I I I it's it's tiring
waking up every day and having to think
about it you know what we need is to
give money to the right people talk to
me about racism yeah give me money
please it's all about economics all
these problems will go away if we just
give the right people money everyone
let's give everybody money why don't we
do that dude let's just [__] burn
this place that's just what we don't
want to do
I just turned a racist encounter into a
joke and
it's the best I can do with it
seven I think it's all economics they
just don't want to give people money
they want to keep money where it is
they're rich and they don't want to give
it up
and they have to
go again
I've never met a democratic billionaire
that I don't I've just never seen that
in my life I've met a billionaire yes
who oh I'm not gonna tell you that rich
on the bus what about Bill Gates
huh Bill Gates
um
Bill Gates I don't know man don't you
think he's a Democrat
I mean you could say that but is he
behind closed doors what was he talking
about and racism and football for
oh uh you asked me what I felt about the
way taxes takes on racism and all that
other stuff and I said to you that this
is always going to be a good old boys
state but in when I think of that
statement I always think of how uh the
NFL just was a hypocritic
[__] uh Escapade of doing that like
uh that's I thought it was the most
ridiculous thing ever except for the
intercept cancer thing they did last
year because as you intercept cancer now
you have the cancer so it's not like you
wanna you don't want to intercept it you
want to deflect the cancer if anything
to the ground so nobody has the cancer
well I think it does not have a Texas is
a license got a lot of flaws
and it's got a lot of awesome things and
I think we can cut out the flaws and
keep the awesome things but I think a
lot of people don't want to do that
they don't want to start that process
yeah I mean uh Austin's whole like thing
is that it is how many cards do you have
is that over eight no it's seven it was
seven one two three four five six seven
yeah but he just took one
did wait hold on hold on hold on hold on
look at all these cards thanks for
showing us here's nine yeah plus this
one
I swear to God is that what piss you off
no it didn't piss me off Texas and
that's what pisses you off I don't give
a [__] man you can say whatever you want
to me man I think Texas is great except
for the bad part it really is like hey
let's just figure out but yeah oh dude
have you ever been to Jasper Texas State
I think California is great okay
I think a lot of different states are
great I don't think Texas is like the
best but I think it is amazing and one
of the best for sure where do you want
to live
I want to live in New York City or
yeah I don't know somewhere like New
York City but cleaner I want to live in
like
uh I don't know Tokyo but where they
speak English and have stand-up comedy
that would be really sick but as a
comedian I think you know we have to get
adjusted to just always moving here you
have a home base but yeah this is always
going to be my home base now you can
steal
you son of a [__] you took my [__]
sheet too I have no access to [__] you
wanna back give me some weed
no I'm not doing that [__] you I'm not
accomplishing your goals
right all right I'm doing making a city
with three
trading three in and have one week
so what do you think about
the open mic scene
who's like what's the best open mic in
town oh I would say how's it go for it
jamisha absolutely definitely anything
run by Alden Schwab
well he's just like the host not if you
want to go home at 8 30 P.M
I like Lucky Duck but no the one of our
staff does not like the comedy I mean
they don't turn the TV off
and it's outside but the only good thing
about
that place is that you get a real
audience because you have people it's an
average audience and it's a big audience
um and he does a tag writing mic before
the 8 PM one that's good too and it it
just helps with writing and
um
he used to uh it's outside it's past the
pandemic we don't have to be outside
anymore let's go back inside
for that
I think the only reason I'm just like
it's better at the lucky duck just in
general just at better venues but I
think the reason why it works at the
lucky duck is because it's outside and
you don't feel trapped like no you're
you're not in a room where the bad jokes
are reverberating you're outside and you
can ignore it yeah which is good and bad
but it's just like such a flawed concept
for a show you're building on like
trapping people best best open mic and
found by far is the Sunday night Mike at
the creek in the cave if you can get on
that because you have an actual audience
thank you [__] yeah Adam Lucky's Mike at
eight o'clock yeah what turn is it um
helped and no smoke by my dating show
that's right before it some of those
people stay over correct get hurt
um I am looking Synergy okay I think
Sunday night's the best I'm willing to
trade a sheep
foreign
I thought that was Tuesdays
do you think that there's too many gays
in Austin I am willing to trade
what yes no there's not enough of them
man let's get them I want I want them
all to come out and [__] hang out
with you because that's your goal
what are you trying to trade here
jimisha what the [__] going on
two sheep for hay yeah two sheep for a
[__] hey get out of town I'm willing
to trade a wood and a sheep for a hay no
Gareth how far is the pizza out uh it I
told you it's coming here around nine
o'clock then I told you I I gave you
well you said nine o'clock again
doesn't it show it on the app I'd eat
another beer and also I think uh I need
a cigarette too that's the thing also oh
my God what happened
cigarette as well so unprofessional yeah
I know it was that was just [__] I'm
a mess
eight
oh my God damn mess
so do you think that maybe we could like
oh survive as a country
if we
band together
no
what the [__] this is what do you say is
this a zombie apocalypse situation at
the end of the day the the the day
Embrace socialism get the [__] out of
here dude did I say I was done did I say
I was [__] done dude don't you think
that we should embrace socialism
communism
I get too many cards
well if we don't take care of ourselves
then we can't really grow as a society
we have to at some point be like hey
let's give money to ourselves
what the [__] are you talking about
that's what the politicians do though
they give money to themselves
not to politicians to people like all of
us not just one group of people
who wants wheat I need a break hey hold
on rock rock rock
I need to do it
wants brick
yep Rock nope sheep
Rock nope
what the hell is that sound what oh the
Roomba okay it's like is there a [__]
drone just flying around down there
holy [__] surprise me
what would surprise you jamisha
[Music]
two
no I did not you you were stone-faced
you did not
hey dude do you know the [__] I've been
from the [__] hood dude okay all
right James
you look like you [__]
pop a cap in my ass
no you don't generic thing you could
have said that was the point 100 that
was that was the whole point thank you
over the settlement this right there oh
no no it goes right there it take you
get rid of this one oh oh sorry do you
know how that do you know how that works
no okay so now that you have
these settlements yeah you can turn them
into cities oh interesting so see the
see the city one yeah you see the issue
with the city for me that I and I
haven't been focusing on it it's because
I have no access to the stuff
um yes thank you thank you uh did you
you knew that right
about the city or not I did yeah okay
because the cartoon uh what's your
what's the favorite place you visited so
far on your tour or Rochester Rochester
yeah really
you liked it that much yeah that's
interesting the most recent
oh he's tickets go for sale
six Jesus with the six
is it me
am I the problem oh my god there was a
frozen camera on the stream this camera
always freezes wait yeah I was gonna ask
that but I
thank you Brian Redman
for letting me know
Brian texted you wait so it's been like
that for
forever I didn't know any better
oops well hopefully you guys didn't make
any interesting facial expressions
no that's all I do that guy was stuck
um but I thought like because it's a
split screen I thought maybe like you
had clicked on the top screen and the
bottom one wasn't
but it's been like that no the whole
game okay okay well thanks for telling
us fruit well I already said so any
better
I didn't know well now we all know that
you didn't know
I think hey thanks hey thanks Brian I
think the sweeper sweeped
I think the roomba's done it's sweeper
swept I sense at home oh he just ended
its flight path right now that didn't
bother you guys it was bothering the
[__] out of me dude I guess we all know
how much you guys like to complain guys
it's like a top three favorite things
this is a clip Factory you could make
Clips here for days when's the pizza
gonna be done I feel like from time to a
brick wall
it's my turn I'm out of the window by
yourself
I swear to God share it pay attention
guys
um looking for some hay I got sheep no
yes I got sheep I want a [__]
brick dude give me a brick I'll give you
what you want Oh done okay
can you do that
and then I have more weight if you need
it we're gonna buy a development card
s
yeah I've tried yeah
foreign
I need like a paper something to clip
this together I'll be back boys
grab a couple yes sir
I can't do
there we go yeah oh it just keeps going
to steal a resource from
um
I think we're going on two hours
we are going on one hour 48 minutes
why are you tired of being broadcast no
I'm good are you impressed that we could
do this so easily so effortlessly I have
such a great podcast
I am looking for some some
hay yeah or uh some wheat willing to
trade
a sheep and a
two sheep
a sheep and a wood
two sheep and one wood
I'm willing to trade two sheep and one
wooden yeah
okay
I have wireless mics we could use but I
was like hey they're set up it's so easy
you can just swing them out of the way
yeah I like these better because you can
plug your headphones into them yeah
you can really control your voice you
did a 17 minute podcast with Patrick 19
with Paul ciphers oh with Paul we've got
almost all of the facts wrong you can't
build right there
it's too close to this orange one
so I can't buy it
uh you can move that road
it's moving here
I should have told you I didn't really
want to
and then we should let her do that but
did she just build the road just let me
do it did she just build the road she
just switched the road I didn't I didn't
just switch did you buy the road
did you buy the road this no no
it's been a while well if it's been a
while what's your friend supposed to be
here Kara yeah yeah she just came up
tell her to come home up or something is
that an ACL hat I will oh I did
all right dude I bought this at ACL I
was [__] dehydrated on a lot of
things and do you have Super Smash Bros
yeah
I have a show oh you have a show whose
turn is it yeah still my turn I'm
waiting for you guys to decide what you
want me to do
uh what do you what what does that mean
she built a ride right here do you think
we should let her put it right I didn't
ask to do that
I can make the decision take the cards
back what what happened I just told you
she wants to move this road right here
do you think that we should let her know
but I don't she didn't even suggest
are you like over something I didn't
want yep well we're allowed to do that
we're allowed to disagree with you and
when you do something not with the rules
I didn't do anything hey
we built a road in a place where it's
not really useful so I felt bad for you
but I don't but you were right about the
fly in the bag
it said get out eventually oh you were
so [__] right about that fly dude
that was ridiculous
so
it doesn't work that way
oh my God
oh my God what's going on over there
what's the matter
hey Gareth can you name all the people
in your shirt hey
for some stuff hey I got
for some Stone
no one has it the Earth
willing to do what is the pizza gonna be
here two wood first stone dude
what is this the Simpsons winner are we
there yet or like what's going on right
now dude get the [__] out of here
uh 8 30 to 8 45 is what it's saying
instead of 20 minutes thank you
100 you're very welcome that was manners
that's what you just uh told me right
now he said they I said you're well this
is how it is how a polite Society works
okay Rich do you think we have a polite
Society [__] yeah
eight
we do
um do you think you deserve politeness
what you've done
to the Chinese what what
have you heard of the Chinese
oh yeah I did totally it was horrible it
was bad you had spelled us it is not
good and you know how much I see you're
Korean dude what are you talking about
us you know how much Asians hate to be
expelled okay do you realize Asia is a
continent and there are sub like
countries inside the continent
geography I'm a human being and I'm also
a European and I'm also German like if
you're like oh French American people
are not that bad it's like hey there's
like different levels of what you are
like I'm an ignorant American a lot of
different things going on I totally
you're totally right like I can adopt
the voice of Asia I can adopt I can say
like hey I'm speaking for human beings
now and we all have
an innate sense of fear oh for sure bud
hey Dave
it's like a poker game no we're about to
see ridge's cards in a second right here
I this is so delayed it's outrageous
this is YouTube
yeah it's just what happens man you have
to I get ready
how bad does my hair look oh my God my
hair is horrible are you done Gareth uh
no I'm [__] not dude chill out bro
this is what it takes to move the game
along at a normal pace
look he's showing us the cards that was
at least 30 seconds delayed that's
that's good we can that was a rock bleep
out all the bad stuff then what bad
stuff would you bleep out
the stuff about America being bad
yeah we need to move that out
giving rich is a fundamentalist and I
respect that about it what is a
fundamentalist it means you're a very
simple you're a simple Folk
he's calm simple dude I call him oh my
God
I'm just a simple farmer that's what
you're trying to do you try it it is why
are you mad at me for pointing out elbow
deep and cow [__] dude
I think
there's a lot of big problems you can
only control what you can control is it
my turn Gareth it is your turn now sir
yes sir uh
mother trucker yes get that out of here
dude seven eight [__]
one two
three all right wait who's winning right
now we got six who's uh Richard Brown so
you're six okay and
Hans is at look at the scorecard seven
it's right here I haven't looked at the
thing yet yeah
why am I still at three I have five dude
what's that about because no one
respects you no get the hell out of here
Hans
you're in charge of this so this means
that you don't respect my my number what
uh what day was it it was yours five
five yeah yes sir okay I'm moving this
the winning number two here I'm gonna
steal from
orange or green they're the same let's
go from jamisha jimisha is more of a
threat sorry
gee
why'd you apologize because I'm stealing
from her but it's also a compliment
because it means I respect her more than
you well you know uh go [__] yourself
Hans how about that also on top of this
I'm happy you didn't respect me enough
to take my one card that I have so I
appreciate my one wood that's all I have
yep that's
I'm still getting rid of my cards
you got a nice lineup two four six
oh yeah eleven eleven yeah well no these
are forever I don't think there's an 11
there's no 11 on the board
oh my God it's so funny
it's probably where the game's taking
forever because we're missing a lot of
the numbers
um and there's multiple people have
limited access to things
Quattro
four
give me that
God these cities are awesome dude love
me a city
five oh [__] son
oh goodness oh damn the rubber got moved
that's right
my buddy loves Katan I'm gonna send him
this
shut up Ridge
what the hell are you talking about dude
what are you gonna send somebody a
picture of your weiner when's the pizza
getting here dude are you all done
Garrett get the [__] out of here
you said nine o'clock right yeah I'm
almost done chill out Holland's all
right over there calm down
did you get a haircut no not for a while
I'm just letting it grow you uh
you looked really Asian the other day
okay that's awesome it was like you had
like a uh did you like you brushed it
all like yeah like it was all in front
of your face and you had it was like
that High School the K-pop it was I
looked like a Nemo yeah you look like
you were about to drop in a K-pop album
you got the longest road now no
absolutely not don't even no oh I'm
coming today I don't know what you're
telling me okay are you done Gary shut
up hold on stop asking me if I'm done
dude
hold on
he's away from my life
now we're tied
and you have the card when you break it
are you breaking it I'm gonna do that
right now okay
how did Garris get all this he suddenly
excelling right now
that's how it goes for me man
that is how it goes for me
yes sir
wait hold on
one two three four five six seven eight
nine change it to seven I'll answer the
hell is that about
you have seven points so yeah wait how
do you have the longest road I rolled a
seven one two three four five six seven
eight wait you're an idiot [__] okay you
still have it never mind
[__] ass [__]
you have nine I know the [__] I counted
after I gave him the card I thought it
was eight I swear to God
you know and I was so unsure that I
counted three times I was like all right
I'm about to say this hopefully I don't
look stupid because I was terrified but
I felt firmly about longest road no you
should have just kicked me in the
[__] jaw jamisha no I'm not that I'm
not I would have been sweet so what do
you guys think about weasels
[__] is your problem I'm sorry from uh I
like weasels I have nothing to steal
from bro uh
um I feel like John half looks like a
hairless mole rat he keeps he keeps
doing bits I'm not doing bits I'm doing
roast jokes you [__] [__]
Jesus Christ don't you think like uh
some people get annoyed by that I'm
sorry my bad Hans I didn't mean to take
everybody's feelings
so seriously
six
Lord lordy
wait who took why did you take something
for six
you don't have a six oh you do oh I'm
sorry but you do you do you do two Woods
there's three sixes
um
so what is this the devil I'm glad he's
the one that ordered the pizza
I'm sure it'll be here soon
oh my goodness
oh it keeps honestly I keep looking at
the the delivery time it keeps moving up
now it's at uh 8 37.
they was telling me nine all right next
are you done yeah
okay not nine so let's see oh [__] you
Hans two wood for jamisha
and what are you gonna do
yes
good are you done
get out of here huh go go go go go go
seven God damn three four five six seven
eight [__] five one two three
maybe that's all I need
that was racist that's the most racist
thing that's been done on this podcast
oh wait
we should go over most racist things
let's
the podcast where the fly landed on my
nose you said that they like black
people
dude hey check this out
[Laughter]
what's going on
three
three hey or we oh no hey there's no
more oh okay
sorry oops oh my goodness [__] is your
deal that's the most crazy what is your
problem right now
Jesus
something's wrong little hissy fish I'm
a little drunk right now
you're a little drunk off of your half a
lone star you had one yeah
I'm getting [__] up God
it's summertime it's starting to start
drinking again
how close are you to
coming oh figuring your [__] up
are you do you ever tell people when
you're coming or do you just are you a
silentcomer
[Music]
um
these are the hard-hitting questions but
I I don't
thing like you can
I would say you can tell
is what I'll say
yeah like there's like emotion and maybe
like a sound that happens
um but I I'm not like an actress
es
I wouldn't have said that but I don't
know what that sound was that's what I
sound like when I come that's what you
doing uh wait hold on I haven't even let
go of the dice yet there's a nine first
of all thank you
oh okay
complete my turn thank you
well I think that it's
I think that years of masturbation have
trained me to come quietly so when I
come I'm just like
profusely was it on purpose oh the only
one like was it natural or did you feel
like it was it like well no so it was it
like Michael J fox shaking or like how
what was the level of shaking uh it was
like sort of a seizure almost it felt
like just like in the lower half of the
body but it wouldn't happen like during
sex it will only happen during ahead
um
so maybe he really likes head yeah
something about that experience yes my
turn's complete thank you
thank you do you think it's like the
idea of
something
your penis in a head people like because
you see heads all the time
if I put my dick in a head
I don't really like what the [__] are
you saying right now I don't really like
[__] so I'm trying to understand you
don't like [__] wait what the [__]
hold on this is an exclusive
I'll be right back hurry up it's
legitimately not very excuses about to
go yeah go get it take care of that
this is a pizza here
no dude Hans has his girlfriend
downstairs right now dude
and she's not coming up here also the
fact of the matter that Hans just said
he doesn't like [__] and then
[__] leaves if you could how do you
how do you say that sentence and then
[__] leave a room
what's your favorite type of uh uh
potato oh chip chip Oh you mean like
okay
um baked
french fries oh twice baked dude I like
a twice baked potato man there's
actually nothing better than it twice is
it kind of like refried beans we've
never had it twice baked potato wait
hold the [__] on Ridge
have y'all never had a twice baked
potatoes
twice baked potatoes or just the [__]
man that's
not a better I gotta get this thing what
does he mean by twice Pig so you haven't
had a twice baked potato like twice it
dries out my eyes my contacts are you
[__] nerds suck dude
it's your the the air is dry
yes you look homeless right now yo dude
I'm rich as [__] I'm Rich As [__] though
I do I am rich
oh my God
holy [__] dude
all right
um did you get the pizza all right whose
train is it no is it my turn
I did just get in the work right now you
guys but if it wasn't oh it's common
seven it's common guys it's Tiffany
seven no that'd be weird okay
okay
no actually jamisha how many cards do
you have jamaicia pause what is your
favorite type of potato
how many cards you have
you gotta get rid of half
I don't have a favorite type of potato
french fries chips
potato french fries oh no
I don't like baked potato
we could have potatoes wait Ridge you
don't know what a twice baked potato is
is that real no I don't explain it to me
okay fast so
baked potato you take out the guts you
take the inside of the potato out and
you mix it with sour cream some salt and
pepper some chives and cheese and then
you put it back into the oven when you
mash it and that makes it into a twice
baked potato then the skin gets all
crispy and [__] then by far best way to
eat a baked potato
two times that [__] Okay
four absolutely that is absolutely the
best way but potato chips are awesome
that's just the most convenient way to
eat a potato playing my night card Hans
what are you at
seven all right over the four oh my God
Hans what's up the weirdest
advertisement you've seen uh going
around places
like I was in Colorado and they were
like yo check out this potato
they're like eat more potatoes and I've
never seen an ad like that before you
see some a weird show like that
traveling no
I won't [__] you my friend
the twice baked potatoes like a double
cream pie
what what
who said that
are you running bits by me you [__]
loser dude
oh my God
this turn is it it's my it's my turn
sorry I'm so impatient I know
uh my turn's over
where's the bathroom
it's by the refrigerator
is it running
Gareth your turn yes sir
six six
uh that's
it
by the refrigerator
did you get it
oh there it goes
did you get is it your turn Gareth uh
yes sir it is my turn I rolled a six uh
now I'm gonna trade in three of these uh
over here
[__] I got her the six wood
jimisha
Jimmy should show up for Road or what
laughs
see this [__] dude you're tied at night
now we're tied at nine I I know how to
do maths you done Gareth you messed up
the first time and you put all the
numbers back three
I play a night
all right did you win Larry disarming
yeah
fill the road
and a settlement
okay good game cool thanks guys
did you just win right now yeah God
[__] damn it I won thank God
all right anything you want to say
jamisha
um you know I really thought that this
was a good game and no one can hear me
right they can hear you
but everyone really
can't focus and finish strong and uh I'm
really proud of what we accomplished and
we kill two flies with one three with
one stone and we injured one three five
we got three flies
with one stone well thank you jamisha
for being on thank you for dealing with
us
all right good night
bye okay
go ahead and finish all of my beers dude
I'm upset
the hell
also I want to set it up oh [__] God
damn another one dude are you [__]
get another one I'm gonna shoot me in
the face Hans hold on
which would actually be hilarious
there it is get them oh yeah take them
down oh damn what happened you got
caught in the spider website let the
spider take over Dude
man
he'll be put it out of its misery no no
no let the spider no I think that that
[__] see you guys aren't Venom
that's okay
is that an old spider web like what is a
cobweb yeah
okay